welcome to biology facts where we talk  about weird but very interesting facts  in biology today we'll talk about  paramedic ants and sometimes fight gang  wars with termites which are their rival  and in this process some ants get  injured the insured ant immediately  secretes volatile pheromones which is  sensed by other category of ants known  as paramedic ants these paramedic ants  immediately take the injured ants on  their shoulders and take them back to  the hive  and this is how they save their life  so  even in ann's colony they have this kind  of social division isn't it amazing let  me know in the comments  and don't forget to subscribe  you can also follow me on social